all of our examples so far have involved
functions G of X that are monotonic in X
at least over the range of X's of
interest let us now look at an example
that involves a non monotonic function
we're going to consider the square
function which has the shape shown in
this diagram and we will assume that X
has a general distribution so that it
can take both positive and negative
values and so over the range of values
of X the function that we're dealing
with is decreasing and then increasing
so it is not monotonic how can we find
the distribution of Y as a warm-up let
us look at the discrete case and as an
example of the calculation let us find a
formula for the probability that the
random variable Y takes a value of 9
this event can happen in two ways it can
happen if X is equal to 3 but it can
also happen if X is equal to negative 3
and these are the two and only two ways
that Y can take a value of 9 we can
generalize this calculation the
probability that the random variable Y
takes on a specific value little Y this
probability can be found by adding the
probabilities of all the different X's
that lead to this particular value now
for x squared to be equal to little Y we
need to have X be equal either to the
positive square root of Y or to be equal
to the negative square root of Y and
this is the general formula for the PMF
of the random variable Y and it involves
two terms because any given value of
little Y can happen in two ways either
by having
X equal to the negative square root of Y
or by having X be equal to the positive
square root of Y we have here a
situation where the function that we're
dealing with is not invertible for a
given value of y we cannot find a single
value of x that will lead to that Y but
instead we typically have two values of
X that lead to that particular Y namely
the positive and the negative square
root of Y so we cannot use the tools
that we used before in the monotonic
case where we dealt with the inverse
function what we can do instead is to
proceed from first principles and
calculate the CDF of the random variable
Y CDF of Y is the probability that the
random variable is less than or equal to
a certain number and we're going to
focus only on the case where that
certain number is non-negative if little
Y is negative then we know that this
probability is going to be 0 because the
random variable Y cannot take negative
values now this is the probability that
the random variable x squared is less
than or equal to Y so what we did here
it is to express this event in terms of
the original random variable capital X
whose PDF is presumably available now
this event is the same as requiring the
absolute value of x to be less than or
equal to the square root of y and this
event again is the same as having the
random variable X be between the
negative and the positive square root of
Y in terms of a picture the random
variable capital y takes a value less
than or equal to this particular little
Y
if and only if the random variable X
falls inside this range now we want to
express this probability in terms of the
CDF of X the probability that we're
looking at the probability of this
interval is equal to the probability
that X is less than or equal to the
square root of y this is the probability
from minus infinity up to square root of
y but from this we need to subtract the
probability of this interval and that
would be the CDF of the random variable
X up to the point square root of y so we
now have an expression for the CDF of Y
in terms of the CDF of X at this point
now we can take derivatives and use the
chain rule the PDF of Y is going to be
equal to the derivative of this
expression the derivative of the first
term by the chain rule is the PDF of X
evaluated at the square root of Y times
the derivative of this argument with
respect to Y which is 1 over 2 square
root Y and then we need the derivative
of the second term we have a minus sign
then the derivative of the CDF which is
the PDF evaluated at minus square root
of Y and then the derivative of this
term with respect to Y which is minus 1
over 2 square root of Y now we have a
minus sign here and a minus sign there
so the two cancel out we can get rid of
this minus 1 term and change this - into
a plus and this is the final form of the
answer
so we see that the PDF of Y evaluated at
a particular point which tells us
something about the probability that the
random variable takes values around this
point has to do with the probabilities
that the random variable X takes values
around here or around there there are
two contributions and this is because
there are two different ways that a
value of y may occur either x falling
here or X falling there